[Music]
there's so much to talk about first of
all you are 20 years old and you are
part of this film that has eight Oscar
nominations congratulations that's just
absolutely incredible and then this
achievement which is really stunning to
watch we watch you grow up in this movie
Entertainment Weekly just came out with
this issue and they put they
photoshopped you at three different ages
on the cover and it's really stunning to
look at there we go right there and it's
you with your younger selves which feels
like it's gotta be trippy for you to
look at first of all I would not wanna I
didn't like my younger self I wouldn't
hang out with him yeah yeah I don't know
they were like like hug hugged them like
you would hug yourself I don't know if I
would hug 12 year old me hopefully the
whole thing is so strange you were six
years old when you were cast for this
film and we have a picture of you then
so literally this is how long you've
been involved in this process when
you're six and you're signing up for a
movie that you tell it they tell you is
gonna take 12 years 13 years to make do
you understand what you're signing up
for I mean I the concept of 12 years is
pretty abstract when you're 16 oh right
the next 12 years is sort of hard to
imagine now but when it's you know more
than twice your life it's a strange but
I mean I understood as much as I could
it was you know it sounded like a cool
idea to you yeah and the way you did it
was you shot for three to four days a
year is that correct yeah about you know
I mean people here 12 years and it
sounds like this massive time commitment
and I mean in a way it was but each year
you know is a week tops you know
including rehearsals and everything so
right it wasn't you know a terribly it
wasn't a burden but you know one thing
it seemed strange to me is when you're a
kid and you're trying to explain to
people what it is you're doing I mean
there's a lot of kids that can say yeah
I just shot a Captain Crunch commercial
it's gonna be on in three weeks and then
they of your friends can see it and be
like a good commercial you're what are
you telling your friends when you're a
kid and do they even believe you because
you're saying you'll see it far in the
future
movie and it's sort of just about life
and it's gonna be out in a decade you
know yeah it's like the new tenant Sato
it's like Richard Linklater Nyko you
know I know who that is but it's okay
well good luck with that yeah I would
think that would be a lie I would have
told on the playground when bullies were
teasing me and I've said back all of you
I'm part of a massive project it will
learn great acclaim in twenty years out
a bit of take the [ __ ] out of me
you're growing up on film and that can
present some problems for you but not
for you I mean I had awkward stages some
say I'm still trapped in an awkward
stage but you at you throughout the
whole film you'd never seem to have an
awkward stage you're growing up I think
we have a sort of a common we see you
grow up and you you always look
self-possessed and and and cool and
interesting at every single age which i
think is i feel a lot more awkward than
you are
I felt pretty awkward but I mean and
also that I mean the film was sort of an
escape for it was kind of a safe place
you know it's a place to kind of explore
the awkwardness of life but you know
through through a fiction so it's not
you know a little less scary than real
life but now I certainly was awkward and
still in well the director as you said
Richard Linklater he would sometimes ask
you for your personal experiences of
what you were going through so when you
started to get interested in girls he
asked you to write down what was going
on with you so that he could maybe
incorporate it into the film yeah yeah
yeah that first that first conversation
with scheana the the big kind of
girlfriend was pretty much directly out
of my head and the things I was you know
spouting it at teenage girls at the time
so now you've got a lot of teenage girls
that are angry at you years ago I saw
what you were thinking about it's like
they can read your diary now from a
while ago exactly that's so strange
you